these coast guards say a hazardous
eruption could happen anytime and
trigger a volcanic tsunami on these
waters and they need to ensure that the
thousands of boats in the area remain
anchored there are those who refuse to
listen not minding the danger around the
lake so we are here because we need to
make sure that no one returns we are now
about 10 kilometers from the volcano but
what you're seeing is just a fraction of
the total area that the Philippine Coast
Guard's actually cover now on the daily
basis since the crisis started and
they're telling us that at the average
they are able to have pre hands around
ten fishermen every day who still head
out to the lake to fish thousands of
fishermen who live and fish here have
been forced to go but some say their
work comes first movie Panama Canal
mogul we didn't know it wasn't allowed
so now I get a buck wait now I have fish
I am worried about safety and effect of
the balcony corruption to our livelihood
- volcano spewed ashes and lava on
Sunday forcing the government to declare
a state of emergency and evacuating more
than 38,000 residents the al volcano is
steeped in folklore and history and is a
popular tourist destination it is also
the second most active volcano in the
Philippines
[Music]
here in the town of a little tug these
residents are performing the suply they
say at a time of such great uncertainty
this ritual dance serves as a powerful
form of Prayer that might appease Mother
Nature Pinella uh I hope God listens to
our prayers and take heed we have always
believed that sibling has helped us
survive since time immemorial the sube
is deeply associated with our volcano
and ballet all of the entire belief
system related to this ritual has to do
with the lake and the volcano those who
have lived around the lake all their
lives have long enjoyed the beauty of
the isle volcano but many are living in
fear of its explosive power Jamila Allen
doggin al-jazeera Batangas province
northern Philippines